[Musique]
Fidel Castro un nom comme une prophétie
pour un dictateur à la longévité
exceptionnelle
[Musique]
le 31 juillet 2006 la télévision cubaine
annonce pourtant l'hospitalisation du
leader maximo et le transfert des
pouvoirs à son frère Raoul Castro jusque
là rester dans l'ombre
[Musique]
depuis cette annonce l'éternel
combattant Fidel Castro a fait que de
bref apparitions publiques
le 17 décembre 2007 dans une lettre lu
par la télévision cubaine Fidel Castro
déclare qu'il renonce à toute fonction
publique
[Musique]
retour sur 50 années autour desquels
Fidel Castro a été la bête noire de 10
présidents américains et à échappé à des
centaines d'attentats formés par la CIA
et les opposants cubains avant de rester
dans les mémoires comme le plus pugnace
des compagnons
[Musique]
fidèle Castro
c'est un avocat un jeune avocat qui
vient de partir orthodoxe ce parti
nationaliste populiste qui
devait probablement gagner les élections
de 52 et qui n'a pas participé aux
élections puisque les élections n'ont
pas eu lieu à cause du coup d'État et
c'est un leader étudiant probablement
proche d'autres générations étudiantes
latino-américaine mais qui est une
génération politique au moment du coup
d'État Batista rien ne bouge à Cuba sauf
la Fédération étudiante universitaire le
reste les syndicats va être atone et la
fidèle Castro va avoir plus tard une
initiative importante il fait appel à la
Cour suprême pour qu'elle condamne le
coup d'État militaire et ce coup d’état
ne sera pas condamné et il Antille comme
conclusion puisque le secoue est un
militaire illégitime n'a pas été
condamné alors l'insurrection elle-même
est légitime Cuba à l'époque
était complètement dans la dépendance
économique des États-Unis et Cuba
n'était pas du tout le pays
sous-développé qu'on a dit
au contraire
[Musique]
c'est à partir des années 20 et du début
de la prohibition aux États-Unis que la
Havane devient une destination de
prédilection
la vanne était alors surnommée le bordel
de l'Amérique
[Musique]
la mafia aux États-Unis était très
importantes et cette mafia avait
organisé des casinos des tripots de jeux
des bordels ou la bourgeoisie des
États-Unis venez jeter un peu sa gourme
Batista était en excellente relation
avec ces mafioso et
il tirait un profit personnel
de tout ce trafic de drogue de de
prostitution de casino etc qui qui se
répandait essentiellement enfin à La
Havane le reste de l'île était
relativement protégé je ne crois pas que
que la dictature de Baptiste se
caractérise seulement par la mafia la
corruption est un des aspects moi je
mettrai plus l'accent sur la répression
sur la peur qu'il y a eu
et je pense aussi sur sur l'incapacité
relatiste a réalisé l'indépendance
économique et politique du pays je vous
mets très beaucoup plus 500 là dessus
quelle était la situation cubaine
économique en terme social politique
avant 1959 c'est un sujet de débat
infini parce que
certains secteurs de l'exil notamment
explique qu'en réalité Cuba était un
pays qui connaissait un certain
développement avant 1959 et qui n'était
pas le pays misérable plein
d'analphabètes qui est décrit par les
Castries qui a été décrit par les
gastristes ensuite je pense qu'on peut
dire quelque part répondait tout à fait
au caractéristique du Sud développement
tel qu'on a l'habitude de le définir
pourquoi parce que vous aviez une ville
la capitale La Havane qui était une
sorte de tête de pont à même pas 200 km
des côtes et qui était une capitale très
développée si on sortait de la capitale
alors on trouvait un paysage totalement
différent avec là une population dans
les campagnes misérables une économie de
minée par le sucre donc une économie
structurellement déformée et qu'il
dépendent du bon vouloir des États-Unis
puisque de surcroît c'est le Congrès
américain qui fixait les quotas de sucre
que Cuba devait conduire c'était
vraiment un régime extrêmement
inégalitaire il y avait une élite de
grands planteurs qui étaient au pouvoir
et le reste de la population
traînait le reste de la population noire
la majorité car là il y avait une
minorité assez importante malgré tout de
population blanche qui formaient une
classe moyenne
tout cela ne pouvait marcher que parce
que Batista avait à s'en servir une
armée aux ordres et une police qui était
extrêmement
riche en espion qui contrôlait un peu la
vie de tous les quartiers je pense qu'on
était dans un pays où effectivement il
fallait pas grand chose pour que les
pour que l'étincelle mettre le feu à la
plaine pour prendre l'expression célèbre
parce que les contradictions économiques
sociales et politiques étaient
explosives alors à ce moment-là c'est
Fidel Castro qui arrive du côté de
Santiago il y a une caserne qu'on
appelle la caserne de montcala qui était
riche en armes et
fidèle décide avec une bande d'amis
recruter un peu
je dis pas un peu par hasard mais mais
sans trop trop de contrôle tous ceux qui
voulaient se lancer dans l'aventure
c'était une aventure
décide d'organiser l'attaque de cette
caserne c'est un fiasco considérable
Raul Castro arrive à échapper fidèle
Castro lui est fait prisonnier
la date du 26 juillet
1953 restera comme le début de la
l'organisation révolutionnaire de Fidel
Castro et dit et du castrisme puisque
c'est la date de l'attaque de cette
caserne de cette fameuse caserne à la
faveur d'une amnistie qui va être
décrétée par
Batista en 1956
fidèle va être libéré il va se dépêcher
d'aller à Mexico rejoindre un certain
nombre de démon cadistes puisque c'est
ainsi qu'on les appelle qui sont allés
se réfugier à Mexico terre d'accueil de
beaucoup d'exilés
révolutionnaire c'est là que fidèle
Castro rencontre un jeune médecin
Argenteuil qui s'appelle Ernesto Che
Guevara
qui est quelqu'un dont la trajectoire
est déjà impressionnante il se rallie
l'équipe qui est sur place avec Fidel
Castro un ancien commandant de espagnol
un ancien républicain espagnol les a
entraînés militairement pour préparer
une guerre de guérilla cette fois-ci un
soir de novembre 1956 il s'entassent à
80 dans un yacht un petit yacht qu'ils
ont acheté d'occasion qui s'appelle le
grand ma
en argot américain Fidel Castro est
tellement impatient que il
décide de débarquer
trois ou quatre heures avant le temps
prévu c'est-à-dire ils ont une journée
de retard à cause du mauvais temps mais
il va débarquer dans un endroit qui
n'était pas prévu où on ne l'attendait
pas et où personne ne l'attendait deux
jours avant
il y avait eu une insurrection une
tentative d'insurrection à Santiago
découvre la capitale de la province
orientale qui devait être coordonnée
avec le débarquement et en fait il y a
pas eu de coordination tout c'est mal
passé un écrivain argentin qui a écrit
une nouvelle là-dessus
considère que c'est plutôt un naufrage
qu'une Cavée débarquement
l'aviation de baptistes sont bombardés
c'est aussi une fois de plus de nombreux
morts mais cette fois-ci à la différence
du monde cada il réussi à gagner la
Sierra Maestra donc gagner la montagne
suivent alors deux ans de guérilla
ou Ernesto Guevara va être nommé par
Fidel Castro le premier commandant de la
Révolution
[Musique]
fidèle
fidelis
[Musique]
février 1958 marque le début des
premières émissions de la radio Rebelde
pendant deux ans jusqu'au 8 janvier 1959
fidèle et ses barbudos vont se battre
contre les troupes de Batista avec
l'appui important des paysans de la
Sierra
maestraliement des paysans se fait en
réaction aux politiques brutale et aux
expropriations orchestrées par Batista
et des grands propriétaires dont
beaucoup sont américains
une grande partie de ces paysans sont
des matchs terroros qui travaillent dans
les plantations de canne à sucre
le mouvement révolutionnaire regroupe
bientôt près de 800 hommes
au terme de ces deux années des varins
va être chargé par Fidel Castro de
marcher sur la Havane en organisant une
colonne qui va être parallèle à une
autre colonne menée par un autre
personnage important à l'époque de la
guérilla de Fidel Castro qui s'appelle
Camillo Sanfo
le guérilla de Fidel Castro est appuyé
largement par le peuple cubain qui se
retourne contre les derniers partisans
de Batista restés après sa fuite c'est
un mouvement populaire collectif et
général qui balaye les dernières traces
de l'ancienne dictature
l'armée de Batista
s'écroule et Fidel Castro arrive
organise une marche triomphale depuis
l'est de Cuba jusqu'à La Havane qui est
presque à l'autre côté ouest 700 km de
distance et plus même et
entrée triomphale et discours non moins
triomphale de Fidel Castro le 8 janvier
1959 début de la Révolution le Fidel
Castro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la Cavagne c'était l'enfer
c'est une ancienne forteresse coloniale
espagnole qui a toujours servi de prison
et le thé a été envoyé par Fidel Castres
dès les premiers jours des le 2 janvier
les premiers jours de la prise du
pouvoir il a été envoyé là-bas pour
prendre le contrôle de cette forteresse
et c'est là que ce sont déroulés
l'essentiel des
exécutions du moins à La Havane parce
qu'il y en avait partout dans le pays
parfois ce n'était pas Desbiens de
Baptiste parfois c'était des gens qui
étaient absolument innocents de crimes
mais les procès étant extrêmement
expéditif c'était systématiquement la
peine de mort comment se fait-il que le
gouvernement américain qui a eu comme
tradition en Amérique latine dans les
Caraïbes en Amérique centrale de
toujours intervenir ne soit pas
intervenu il faut le dire que le l'issue
de la guerre pourrait pu être très
différente je pense que le gouvernement
américain était mal informé de ce qui se
passait réellement et sans doute une
sous-estimation aussi de ce qui était la
dynamique de l'armée rebelle et de
la direction de fidèle Castro et du
mouvement du 26 juillet
comme beaucoup de jeunes ne ma
génération
très vite on a pris fête écho pour la
révolution cubaine pour des tas de
raisons d'abord sa rompait un peu avec
tous les modèles bureaucratiques qu'on
avait connu ça nous semblait une rupture
un peu avec la langue de bois ce qui se
passait dans les pays de l'Est en Union
soviétique donc c'était pour nous une
révolution du nouvel période
[Musique]
il y a des auteurs qui ont prétendu que
Fidel Castro était déjà communiste avant
pour ma part je ne le crois pas que
c'était plutôt quelqu'un je dirais qui
était un personnage un nationalisme très
radical qui avait une volonté de justice
sociale mais
rien n'indique que avant la prise du
pouvoir il était
convaincu qu'il fallait instaurer un
pouvoir socialiste de type soviétique
ignore encore qu'il est devenu
communiste ou marxiste il s'est marxisé
au contact du Che et au contact de
certains autres mais surtout au contact
du check pendant
la Sierra m'a extra la bourgeoisie
cubaine qui a peur du communisme et qui
est encore dans cette optique
anti-communiste de l'immédiata pré
guerre
influencé par les États-Unis
ne le sait pas les grands latifs
mondiales les grandes propriétés
foncières notamment celle qui celle où
le sucre est cultivé appartiennent pour
les deux tiers à des compagnies
américaines il y en a été de foot ce qui
explique qu'une partie de cette
bourgeoisie cubaine de cette bourgeoisie
sucrière minoritaire va pendant une
période financer l'insurrection armée de
fidèle Castro précisément parce que elle
voudrait bien se débarrasser de ces
grands latifonistes
nord-américain Fidel Castro
dissimule un peu son jeu il envoie le
dangereux
marxiste gavara étranger
faire une tournée de propagande pour
Cuba à travers le monde à travers
surtout le tiers-monde et ce n'est qu'au
bout d'un an un an et demi que il a basc
s'écartes qu'il nationalise
une partie de l'économie cubaine
[Musique]
pavé dans la mare des relations
États-Unis Cuba dans le discours qu'il a
prononcé en dépit de sa maladie au
premier congrès des jeunesses
latino-américaines il a annoncé
l'expropriation et la nationalisation
des compagnies américaines de Cuba cette
décision touche des affaires telles que
la compagnie cubaine d'électricité les
eaux standards et la Texaco dont la
valeur s'élève à quelques 400 milliards
d'anciens francs nouvel épisode dans la
tension americano cubaine
les Américains commencent à se rendre
compte que eux qui au début avaient
applaudit en quelque sorte
la démarche de gastro qui était celle
d'un révolutionnaire disons démocratique
entre guillemets il s'aperçoivent qu'ils
ont laissé rentrer le loup dans la
bergerie le régime qui se met en place
avec
Fidel Castro c'est un régime qui est en
effet en décalage total avec l'ambiance
générale de l'Amérique latine de de
cette période de guerre froide on a dans
de grands pays du Sud de du continent
des régimes qui se sont installés après
des coups d'État en réaction à ce qu'on
appelle déjà à l'époque des
gouvernements populistes c'est la fin de
Juan Domingo perron en Argentine
c'est également
le cas au Brésil
en 54 j'ai tout lu au Vargas qui est
revenu au pouvoir de façon légale va
être poussé au suicide
face à l'embargo subit dès les années 60
Cuba doit affirmer la souveraineté de
son régime en réponse aux multiples
provocations et violations de son espace
aérien par les anti-castristes
en effet Cuba avait commis un crime de
l'aise magister sans prendre au bien de
multinationales américaines comme la
United company
face aux attaques qui sont en train de
se préparer de la part de Washington la
direction
révolutionnaire en particulier Castro et
guevaraz cherche des appuis face à ce
qu'ils comprennent très vite face à ceux
qui va être une rupture avec qui semble
inéluctable et rapide avec le
gouvernement américain et ses appuis ils
vont les trouver où et bien ils vont les
trouver à Moscou la réaction des
États-Unis a été tellement forte les
ennemis qui avait installé ce dictateur
Batista au pouvoir
que les l'URSS est venu tout de suite on
appuie à gastro et il y a eu un
glissement progressif du régime
castriste dans
ce qui était l'affrontement Est-Ouest et
l'URSS pensant que il y avait une tête
de pont dans le continent américain qui
pouvait être créé à travers de Cuba et
c'est à partir de ce moment là je parle
nous sommes déjà dans les années 60 que
les États-Unis décident d'en finir avec
ce dangereux individu le
président-ezzanova donne l'ordre de
préparer un programme complet et
clandestin le Cuba project pour détruire
le nouveau gouvernement cubain lorsque
le président John Kennedy accède au
pouvoir il reprend le programme à son
compte
ils organisent les États-Unis un
débarquement à Cuba avec une quantité
d'exilés cubain
persuadé que la population va se rallier
aux
contre-révolutionnaire qui débarque dès
que on saura que il revienne apporter la
démocratie c'est une idée très bizarre
parce que
pendant ces deux premières années la
plus populaire à la révolution est
absolument immense c'est ça je crois que
tous les historiens les chercheurs sont
d'accord mais on a une fois de plus à
Washington une idée fausse avec des
renseignements de la CIA et des analyses
erronées le CIA armé entraîne 1500
hommes de la brigade 2506 tout s'exil et
cubains opposés à Fidel Castro et les
largues sur la côte cubaine dans le but
de renverser le régime
les troupes cubaines réagissent aussitôt
et repoussent la tentative de
débarquement dans la baie des Cochons au
nord de Cuba fidèle prend lui-même la
direction des opérations sans le soutien
de l'aviation américaine l'opération
échoue et les 800 survivants sont faits
prisonniers
[Musique]
en trois jours c'est trop peur vont être
vaincus et le
régime castriste remporte une victoire
éclatante on dira que la baie des
Cochons a été la première victoire ça va
être le slogan qui va se répandre dans
la même latine la première victoire de
contre l'impérialisme américain en
Amérique latine les mercenaires sont
capturés et l'aventure va se terminer
par une défaite et militaire et
diplomatique pour Washington le fiasco
de du débarquement raté de la baie des
Cochons va marquer pour les États-Unis
une date importante on va s'apercevoir
qu'il n'est pas si facile de se
débarrasser de fidèles Castro et final
Castro lui à partir de ce moment-là se
tourne d'une manière délibérée vers
l'Union soviétique pour demander l'appui
de l'Union soviétique
ce qui va déclencher une nouvelle crise
en 1962 qui est ce qu'on appelle la
crise des fusées les Nikita couchev
installe des missiles
à 100 ogives encore nucléaire à Cuba et
les avions espions des États-Unis s'en
rendre compte et à ce moment-là il y a
une un bras de fer qui s'établit entre
Kennedy et krokchef
et Kennedy l'emporte
VF furieux
que contient et pris la décision de
retirer les fusées pour fidèle c'était
une trahison c'était une trahison parce
que il voulait un affrontement direct
avec les Américains
et
mesurer les forces d'un camp et de
l'autre
il n'y a quelque chose qui tient de la
mégalomanie encore une fois de
l'inconscience on a eu raison de dire
qu'à ce moment-là la paix ne tenait plus
qu'à un fil
[Musique]
garder de toute appui
direct dans au grillard l'accident
américain entre
l'Union soviétique et Fidel Castres il y
a eu une espèce de marchandage d'accord
vous retirez les fusées de toute façon
les Soviétiques ils n'ont pas consulté
fidèles pour la résolution de la crise
ils ont directement traité avec Kennedy
mais ils lui ont donné disons un petit
une petite consolation
à savoir que les cumin pourrait
intervenir sur d'autres côté théâtres
d'opérations à travers le monde
bien des années plus tard on a publié
les lettres que que fidèle avait envoyé
un Nikita coup de chauffe
et
on peut pas considérer cela autrement
que du délire
il lit dans une des lettres et qu'il
faudrait envoyer
de manière préventive
un missile sur une grande ville
américaine
l'année suivante
a été reçu en Union soviétique et il
s'est un peu assagi c'est à dire que il
a suivi des orientations données par les
Soviétiques
dans le sens d'une d'un plus grand
réalisme économique contre les doctrines
du Che l'Union soviétique comprend que
il faut tenir à bout de bras l'économie
cubaine et
au
prix de je ne sais combien de millions
de dollars par jour l'Union soviétique
maintient par une espèce de poumon
artificiel en vie l'économie cubaine qui
hésite entre le tout sucre le pas assez
sucre l'industrialisation etc et c'est
l'armée qui commence à intervenir dans
l'économie c'est-à-dire ce qu'on appelle
les phares c'est à dire les forces
armées révolutionnaires
cette dérive soviétique je dirais du
régime cubain va évidemment provoquer
les années 60 des tensions au sein même
du groupe de Don Fidel Castro a pris la
direction il arrive donc à Monsieur
Guevara
de se rendre compte que il y a deux
réalités lui qui était si pro-soviétique
au début
s'aperçoit que les soviétiques
sont
internationalistes du bout des lèvres
mais ne mettent pas leur doctrine
anti-impérialiste en pratique
auprès des pays du tiers-monde ce qui
explique le fameux discours d'Alger de
1965 ce jour-là Che Guevara ira trop
loin on l'entend conspu un coulisse les
délégués soviétiques et lors de son
discours dénoncé avec virulence la
complaisance du Kremlin envers la Maison
Blanche
de retour à Cuba la confiance laisse
rapidement place à l'inquiétude dans le
regard du Che et c'est finalement la
tête baissée qu'il vient à la rencontre
de Fidel Castro et Oswaldo d'horticos
alors encore président de la République
derrière les sourires de façade
l'attention est palpable Castro cherche
du regard se fissent qu'il a déçu mais
le ched détourne les yeux sous le poids
de l'accusation silencieuse
et l'emmène avec lui dans une résidence
une des nombreuses résidences dont Astro
dispose dans l'île et il a il y a un
entretien à huis clos dont on ne sait
rien si ce n'est que par les gardes du
corps que il les entendait gueuler l'un
et l'autre pendant des heures et des
heures il paraît que la discussion a
duré près de 24 heures on se demande
quand est-ce qu'il dormait
en tout cas à partir de ce moment là
Guevara disparaît complètement de la
circulation on ne sait pas très bien si
le check est parti en Amérique latine en
Afrique de son plein gré ou si gastro
n'était pas assez content aussi de
voir partir quelqu'un qui peut-être
avait une aura telle qu'il aurait pu lui
faire de long qui va à comprendre qui
n'a plus sa place à Cuba et il décide
lui qui vient de d'Afrique d'aller
organiser une guérilla contre
l'impérialisme des Belges qui existent
encore au Congo
[Musique]
tentative de guérilla or
dans les médias cubains télévision
cubaines les presque humaine on commence
à se demander au bout de quelques
semaines et même de quelques mois
surtout la prestationale et la presse
internationale mais où est le devenu le
Tchèque qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et
fidèle pour se débarrasser du problème
va rendre un mauvais service
d'une manière délibérée ou pas la
question se pose encore va rendre un
mauvais service à Guevara il va lire en
public au cours du congrès du Parti
communiste cubain d'octobre 1965 la
lettre d'adieu que le Dieu lui a laissé
[Applaudissements]
la lecture publique de cette lettre
était une condamnation à l'exil
éternelle du thé fidèle
lui donne le les 17 ou 18
guerriers héros dont il a besoin pour
aller se battre sur un autre front cette
fois en Amérique latine et c'est la
Bolivie son expérience bolivienne va
être catastrophique et il sera donc
assassiné en 67 exit
[Musique]
veste
les pouces au secours
ce qui est dans la
[Musique]
retire les rentrer dans la gloire
et fidèle
on pourrait s'en servir comme icône
universel et comme image éternelle de la
Révolution Cubaine toujours jeune et
toujours compatible
qu'il meurt en Marty c'était
le
plus beau cadeau qui pouvait lui donner
on va se trouver en 1970 dans une
situation où le pays est acculé à
se replier sur l'Union soviétique et a
adopter à s'intégrer dans le Comic-Con
autrement dit dans le marché commun qui
regroupait à l'époque l'URSS et les pays
d'Europe de l'Est le prix à payer sera
très grave parce que cette intégration
dans le ce qu'on appelait le camp
socialiste entre guillemets va signifier
pour Cuba 1 la persistance de la
dépendance du sucre
cette fois ci ça n'est plus le sucre
qu'on exporte aux États-Unis l'exporte à
Moscou sans qu'il y a véritable
processus d'industrialisation
ni de développement
d'autre part sur le plan institutionnel
et politique ce sont les beaucoup de
choses vont être copiées sur le modèle
soviétique et ça s'avérera assez
catastrophique évidemment ça a permis à
la direction cubaine des réalisations
authentiques surtout si on compare la
situation de la population à Cuba et des
jeunes avec toutes les îles alentours
bien et bon le service de santé qui est
un modèle
l'éducation et même d'un certain point
de vue je veux dire un niveau de vie qui
était quand même bien supérieur à toutes
les
îles de la Caraïbe et puis après bon il
y a l'autre côté de la médaille parce
que moi on peut appeler une certaine
bureaucratisation d'une révolution
authentique bon quand même cette affaire
d'absence de pluralisme politique un
seul parti dans le parti quasiment pas
de débat en tout cas pas de débat public
une seule presse une seule radio une
seule télé un quotidien gramma
absolument illisible et ensuite après il
y a eu quand même toutes ces vagues de
répression ce qui est lié quand il y a
pas de pluraline de débat véritable à ce
moment-là on aurait pris ce qui qui
parce que ça existe qui veulent
absolument débattre on peut dire voilà
en résumé de 70 à 90 c'est toute
l'influence soviétique qui va peser sur
Cuba et certes l'aide économique et
financière va être très grande mais le
prix à payer à long terme sur le plan
politique va être extrêmement lourd et
alors évidemment à partir de la chute du
mur de Berlin à partir de 1989 là
lorsque les le
poumon artificiel cesse de fonctionner à
partir de ce moment-là c'est ce qu'on
appelle la période spéciale les soutiens
que la Russie accordé à Cuba que l'URSS
accordé à Cuba vont se réduire de
manière considérable Cuba commence à à
sentir le poids de la difficulté
économique Cuba est en train de
redevenir un pays du tiers-monde chose
qu'il avait cessé c'est d'être depuis
pratiquement trois décennies le pays
était un pays dévasté quand on allait à
Cuba dans au début des années 90 on se
demandait comment le pays allait pouvoir
rebondir
il a fallu que Cuba réapprenne à vivre
de ses propres ressources et ça ça pas
été facile
le régime c'est évidemment durci le au
plan politique au plan économique
évidemment au plan des libertés la on a
commencé de plus en plus à parler de
dictature
d'où la frénésie avec laquelle dès que
il a été possible de quitter Cuba
quantité de cubain on manifesté pour
pouvoir aller en Floride et de là
peut-être ailleurs et ça a été toute la
crise très très grande qu'on a appelé
des balcers c'est d'ailleurs c'est Jean
qui met sur un pneu gonflé
traverser le bras de mer qui sépare Cuba
de Miami la plupart de ces cubaines exil
ont on fait fortune et pratiquement ce
sont eux qui dirig ent la politique des
États-Unis à l'égard de Cuba
le gouvernement décide de légaliser le
dollar en 1993 il légalise le dollar
pourquoi parce que les familles
exilées vont envoyer de l'argent en voie
de l'argent à leurs parents à Cuba et
avec cet argent si le dollar et légalisé
bien on peut penser que les cubes avant
aller acheter des biens dans des
boutiques spéciales où on trouve plein
de choses qu'on ne trouve désormais plus
du tout à Cuba et le gouvernement lui
encaisse ces dollars et donc
assainie sa situation financière
extrêmement difficile il n'était pas
question pour Fidel Castro de
modifier quoi que ce soit au canon du
socialisme étatique mais en revanche il
a essayé d'investir dans le tourisme il
a passé des accords avec des entreprises
de tourisme
étrangères il va autoriser les activités
privées de certains petits artisans de
certains petits métiers peu que la
société cubaine s'est mise à marcher à
deux vitesses avec une société qui
utilisait du dollar et une autre qui
n'utilisait que le pesso jusqu'à l'année
2004 où on va mettre un terme à la
circulation du dollar ce qui s'accumule
c'est une situation de fragmentation
sociale et d'inégalités très grande
où la pyramide des Cubains disent
toujours la pyramide sociale c'est
inversée désormais vous laver la
vaisselle dans un petit restaurant privé
et vous pouvez gagner jusqu'à 100
dollars par mois ou 120 dollars par mois
vous êtes chirurgien vous êtes médecin
vous êtes ingénieur vous êtes professeur
vous vous retrouvez dans une situation
catastrophique vous ne pouvez pas
survivre avec votre salaire et il faut
faire autre chose en réaction à la
politique socialiste menée par Fidel
Castro des exilés cubains souvent aidés
par la CIA forme des groupes par
militaires ces groupes se nomment entre
autres alfa66 la Fondation nationale
cubano-américaine commande au F4 ou les
frères du secours et réalisent des
attentats et des opérations de sabotage
contre Cuba et le régime en place
il n'y a pas de possibilités pour les
Américains sauf cas de crise très très
très grave il y a pas d'intérêt pour les
Etats-Unis d'envahir Cuba mais
Fidel Castro
et fait voir constamment la menace de
guerre une guerre complètement
imaginaire
et tout le monde est complètement
mobilisé tout le temps mobilisé à Cuba
face au risque toujours présent d'une
d'une hégémonie d'un retour des
États-Unis et d'un retour des exilés il
y a une capacité de résilience dans la
population cubaine ça c'est tout
l'ambiguïté de Cuba où à la fois il y a
un espèce de respect Fidel Castro parce
que le leader de la révolution il s'est
battu jusqu'au bout quand les Américains
et puis en même temps des des choses
avec lesquelles beaucoup de gens sont en
désaccord c'est cette contradiction là
ces difficultés qui vont avoir un effet
désintégrateur dans la société cubaine
les jeunes qui sont nés dans les années
90 nous connu que la crise donc cette
jeunesse elle voit quoi de la Révolution
ce qu'elle voit c'est pas c'est pas
réjouissant
et sans même parler des plus jeunes mais
la génération intermédiaire les gens qui
ont connu bâtisserie qui ont connu la
dictature sont maintenant minoritaires
la plupart les autres sont nés après
1959 et la dictature de Batista c'est
quelque chose qui est lointain et ce
qu'ils connaissent c'est un pays qui
pour certains d'entre eux a beaucoup
amélioré leur situation sociale dans les
années 80 avant la fin de bien
soviétique mais c'est plus le cas donc
il y a déjà des secteurs de la
population démoralisée des secteurs de
la population je pense minoritaire qui
sont hostiles et qui pensent qu'il faut
changer
la santé ici il y a beaucoup
d'inconvénients
par exemple nous ne sommes pas libres
pour sortir pour faire du tourisme
si c'est pas pour ton travail
ou pour servir dans l'armée
par Fidel Castro la direction cubaine
c'est qu'il faut revenir en arrière sur
toutes ces mesures il faut faire autre
chose alors on va revenir en arrière
d'autant plus facilement qu'il y a un
nouvel un nouveau partenaire qui va
beaucoup aider et qui est le Venezuela
double Chavez j'avais c'est arrivé comme
Zorro et
et le grand homme de Chaves c'est Fidel
Castro Chavez
et quelqu'un qui ne pardonnera jamais
aux États-Unis d'avoir fomenté contre
lui qui a été élu régulièrement à la
loyale au Venezuela un coup d'État qui a
failli réussir mais qui a raté
contre la pauvreté l'analphabétisme
la
marginalisation de fractions
considérable de la population
vénézuélienne et Cuba va offrir à au
Venezuela les médecins et les
instituteurs dont le Venezuela a besoin
pour permettre à la santé de fonctionner
et pour lancer des campagnes
d'alphabétisation et en contrepartie le
Venezuela fournit du pétrole à bas prix
ça soulage Cuba mais Cuba ne pourra
jamais marcher sérieusement tant qu'il
ne remettra pas des usines en route et
il ne pourra pas il ne pourra remettre
les usines en route que lorsqu'il aura
des capit aux qui lui permettront de
redémarrer ça c'est le actuellement Cuba
vit encore une fois avec
des petits poumons artificiels non plus
le gros soviétique ex soviétique mais
avec
tourisme pétrole
échange troc
mais vivent mal
le 17 décembre 2007 dans une lettre lu
par la télévision cubaine Fidel Castro
déclare qu'il renonce à toute fonction
publique
il semble de plus en plus certains que
le pouvoir est en train de se transférer
comme il l'avait prévu à son frère
Raoul Castro qui est par ailleurs le
chef de l'armée Jean Castro
ne pourra pas réaliser une transition
démocratique parce que ce n'est pas un
démocrate
il peut réussir
peut-être un succession ne fait le
castre qui très vite l'échappera des
mains dans le sens de
une plus grande
[Musique]
ouverture les jambes demanderont
beaucoup plus très vite et lui ne sera
pas capable d'y répondre ce personnage
évidemment aujourd'hui
paraît comme
le personnage qui est le leader d'un
groupe qu'on appelle l'os duos les dures
ceux qui sont apparemment les gardiens
de l'orthodoxie monolithique stalinienne
je ne serai pas du tout étonné que ce
soit l'homme par qui une certaine
ouverture de l'économie arrive il a déjà
commencé Raoul Castro
se retrouve dans une situation où il va
devoir essayer
de prendre
d'améliorer un peu
s'il réussit la situation peut être
stable pendant un certain temps mais
dans cinq ans peut-être même avant il
peut même lui-même être victime de
maladies autres dans ce cas de figure la
génération intermédiaire qu'on connaît
on connaît les dirigeants cubains il y a
des gens qui sont capables mais c'est
cette nouvelle génération elle elle ne
pourra pas contourner indéfiniment les
problèmes clés qui se posent pour le
pays les confrontations politiques à
Cuba depuis la prise du pouvoir elles
ont été arbitrées par Fidel Castro
Raoul Castro sur le court terme peut les
gérer et mais après il faudra bien qu'il
y ait des éléments du groupe dirigeants
qui choisissent l'option de la
négociation je vois pas d'autre issues à
plus ou moins brève échéance de mettre
en oeuvre une libéralisation du régime
qui
a plus ou moins long terme des
boucherait quand même sur une démocratie
politique qui permettrait justement de
mettre en oeuvre également des éléments
de de démocratie économique et sociale
moi je ne crois pas qu'il y ait pro
qu'il y ait qu'on puisse parler d'un
effondrement total du régime les choses
ne vont pas
se traduire par d'une manière
révolutionnaire
il va y avoir
à mon avis une transition à la chinoise
pour moi s'accumulerait tous les
inconvénients c'est à dire que le régime
cubain
s'autoriserait à rester extrêmement
répressif et autoritaire parce qu'il
parviendrait à mettre en oeuvre une
croissance économique assez importante
pour permettre de revenir à un système
de redistribution qui permettrait
d'apaiser les tensions sociales au-delà
c'est le peuple cubain c'est l'évolution
de la société internationale
qui y aura-t-il comme président aux
États-Unis quelle altitude ce président
aura-t-il vis-à-vis de Cuba aura-t-il
une attitude
revancharde comme une partie de la
classe politique
au pouvoir à Washington le souhaite
aura-t-il une attitude Concil Iante
comme une autre partie de la classe
politique à Washington le souhaite
là c'est vraiment des des scénarios qui
nous échappent
[Musique]